but okay but you have to keep in mind
we're talking to someone who doesn't
like ketchup yeah so
so what the [ __ ] okay okay before we go
into more in-depth food discussion gaunt
doesn't like condiments
basically i just like the way things are
meant to taste so barbecue sauce no
no no ketchup i just i just know we're
gonna go through all the combinations
to make sure yeah mustard mustard if
it's not like
if it's just like the beans mayo you
don't like any mayonnaise
mayo tabasco or anything like that maybe
savask
i don't really see that as a condiment
it's something like if i need an extra
kick to make it more spicy so when you
eat like fries it's just plain
yeah it's just salt and pepper so it's
just salt and pepper so
sad no that's why i like my thin fries
because it like absorbs
the spices
we said that the other day like because
we were talking about how we like the
thick
like cut fries yeah i like the thin
fries yeah
but then god was like oh i don't like
the thick fries because i taste the
potato
i'm like yeah that's what a chip is no i
want
i want to taste you know the oil this
can sound so bad
like it's the oil flavor or the salt and
all the salt and pepper
flavor if it's like too much potato
you're just eating it just feels like
you're eating starch
with no flavor but sometimes if it's
done perfectly that starch is just
fluffy and beautiful and it works so
well when you put it with like ketchup
or like mayonnaise or you know whatever
you do when you mix the ketchup and mayo
together you get a nice
that bite me gag so bad man i i [ __ ]
hate ketchup and mayo like
ketchup and mayo go with your dick
like by themselves i like are like
disgusting enough to me
but to mix them together and they form
this like pink color i'm just like oh
get
get that [ __ ] out of my face man is so
good
so like can you or can you like go into
like i can't be the only one here i
can't be the only [ __ ] one
in this case you are the only one when
you go into like uh any like
normal chain in the uk you can't get it
because it's called burger sauce right
yeah
but it's all thousand island sauce just
a thousand answers yeah i love thousands
but they don't they don't do it in like
mcdonald's kfc or ever
that's like ranch with ketchup right i
think so but mayo with uh
mayo with ketchup mix this is burger
sauce in the uk oh yeah it's called the
fried one it's all fry sauce
okay yeah yeah and you can't get it
unless you go to those like dirty
chicken shops
in like london you go to them and you
gotta like [ __ ] haggle with them just
to get like
the [ __ ] like ketchup they're like
they're so stingy bro they won't give
you anything
and i used to go into mine all the time
dude and i felt like i was getting
mugged off
because i was like the only white guy in
this area and i would always go in like
yes
i would like um five wings uh a burger
and then
people come in like yo what's up boss
man i'll have uh the wings set and i'm
like [ __ ] dude don't just
cry i felt so out of place because i
just didn't know how to talk
do i say boss man to the guy can i say
boss man is that weird
i feel weird going yes i'll just take a
fry please and uh
tango you know i'll take a fry bus man
yeah and i just felt bad when there was
like 12 year olds like fighting in the
area next to me and i'm just trying to
order the chicken i'm like i just
can't have burger sauce please while the
other guys are [ __ ] like jumping over
the counter to grab it right they would
do that they would put their hands over
the counter and grab the [ __ ]
really yeah the [ __ ] owners the
[ __ ] audacity i know the audacity of
these pictures actually there is one
source that i do like
it's very specific but it's peri-peri
are they in the same category it's like
a marinade yeah that's because like
i i feel like if it's more on like the
marinade side of things i love
that that's like teriyaki right yeah
yeah exactly like like nando's in
australia
yeah we do but it's [ __ ] expensive oh
so no one goes too amazing in the uk
i [ __ ] miss nando's here i miss it so
cheeky nandos
yeah to be fair i feel uk now i tried
nando's in the uk
infinitely better than yeah people
always chat [ __ ] about it but like
the thing is is that it's like the
perfect in between a fast food place in
a restaurant where sometimes you just
want the chicken and you want to get out
like right you still feel like [ __ ] it's
one of the few places in the uk that we
can be proud of in terms of like food
because
when you think of british cuisines you
like you're like what what can we be
proud about
oh yeah beans on toast that's british
cuisine right man
what's with british people getting
bullied online all the time now man what
remember when it used to be british
people were like cool in 2012 and harry
potter was in full steam and yeah tumblr
loved british people
and then now it's just like i said chose
day he said
stay in it
he likes beans yes i like beans on toast
okay i can eat it
as many times as i need to god damn it
there's a limit with me with
beans yeah why do you say beans like
that
because that's a funny word i love like
joining the b and b i can imagine if i
wasn't born in the uk i would think
baked beans are just like why would you
ever eat baked beans well i mean because
in australia we eat baked beans quite
often as well yeah like
you can sometimes i would eat it on
toast sometimes i would just [ __ ]
crack open
yeah in university i basically lived off
just beans and cans and i would just
heat them up and eat them for dinner
that sounds disgusting to me oh yeah i
i didn't know how to cook so i would
just boil pasta and put salt on it yeah
yeah and eat the pasta
i love how the cooking experience at
university is just how many how many
ways can i cook
pasta it's just that it took me like a
year to figure out that you could just
pour the pot sources on top of the pasta
because i was so like content and i
didn't want to look stupid in front of
my uni
yeah and i remember my mum like offered
to teach me how to cook and i was like i
don't need that
yeah how hard can it be i got this how
hard can it be so yeah i was eating like
plain pasta and beans for like
a year yeah it's pretty depressing